this is super interesting and maybe not
completely surprising to you
white house data has now leaked which
shows
that the white house knows that
infections are spiking
in rural trump voting areas while they
continue to decline
in some of those early hit
disproportionately urban
blue voting areas and the growing
political divide that has long permeated
the country
when it comes to attitudes towards
coronavirus as we know
democrats much more likely to be taking
the virus seriously than republicans
democrats much more likely to be
staying at home than republicans
democrats much more likely to be wearing
masks than republicans
that now which has been a political
divide for some time
is being reflected in the case and death
growth rates now the trumpists will say
listen most of the deaths are still in
blue areas
these liberal cities like new york city
and
the surrounding new jersey uh towns and
cities chicago
detroit boston now of course those
places
also have in common that they are very
dense cities
with huge numbers of direct flights to
and from china and europe so
that explains why those places were
early hubs
and why they were places with
significant infection early
before we had any testing and before we
knew much about the prevalence and the
spread of coronavirus
but in terms of percentages which is
really where you have to look if you
want to evaluate a virus
it's called viral spread for a what for
a reason we are now seeing that most of
those early hot spots
on a percentage basis are actually on a
decline whereas
some of the fastest growth rate spots
are for example
texas florida and georgia now just to
put some numbers to it
check out the case growth rates
yesterday these are not raw numbers
what you want to look at is the rate of
growth
which is a trajectory okay you look at
yesterday
tennessee virginia texas georgia and
florida
all had dramatically larger case growth
rates than massachusetts and new york
massachusetts right at 1 percent new
york at 0.43 percent
tennessee 3.5 percent growth rate
yesterday and so what you have to
understand
is that over time the
raw numbers are going to spike you look
at
tennessee in cases and you might say oh
okay well they went from
you know 600 to 650 cases but
if that rate continues it becomes a huge
hot spot very very quickly
so that gets us to this leaked data the
white house has
a number of uh slides which have leaked
that show that this is a trend the white
house is aware of you've got rates
decreasing in 14 states rates increasing
in nine
states but 27 states don't even have
enough
testing yet that we can say for sure
that all of the cases are even close to
being counted accurately
but here's where it gets really
interesting the state level data
may not really be enough to underscore
this
dr burks and others for a while now have
been saying
we really need to look at counties you
need to look at counties to see what's
going on
that helps to separate urban versus
rural it helps to separate
parts of states from each other it turns
out that when you look at the county
level
the biggest spikes are happening in
rural
trump voting counties in places like
kansas and tennessee
some of those places have seen case
growth rates of more than
a thousand percent in a single week
there are rural trump counties in
missouri
nebraska minnesota wisconsin which lean
heavily trump the counties do where
cases have grown
400 percent all but one of the top 10
growth counties in the last week
were trump counties in 2016. dr
john ross who's a professor at harvard
harvard medical school tweeted about
this saying quote
the fastest rising areas in the u.s for
covid cases are
very white and very trumpy according to
this slide
somebody leaked to nbc news this is why
i do not believe
that trump's strategy of just
normalizing the deaths
and pretending we've won is going to
work
it could work for some time there's no
question about it because right now
the growth rates are very high in a lot
of these trump counties
but the raw numbers are still small if
you go from 100
to 200 new cases per day it's 100
percent increase
but it's still only 200 cases it's not
going to get as much attention
particularly when a lot of times people
are sorting the data by
most new cases today which will favor
states with larger populations and
states with
early infections but if then you go from
200 new cases a day to 400
to 800 to 1600 and then cumulative
cumulatively you're talking about a huge
number of infections
so what that says to me is the trump
strategy of saying
we won we've prevailed we're on the
decline
we've got testing we've got everything
the economy is going to reopen third
quarter will be transitional fourth
quarter is going to be amazing 2021 is
going to be the best in history this
type of stuff
it ignores that if these growth rates
continue another 30 days
and we said this 10 days ago and now a
lot of these states are the leaders in
growth rate
if it's another 30 days of this you are
going to have
very red states that presumably local
news is still going to report on cases
and deaths
national news is going to point to these
states as the new hot spots
i don't believe that it is viable for
trump to simply pretend everything is
fine until november
if indeed these places continue spiking
um also interesting somebody leaked this
data
that means that someone inside the white
house and
inside or close to the task force i
don't mean like dr burks but there's so
much staff that's associated
uh they probably decided to leak this
because
they realized they need to because of
what the public position of trump has
been
you see trump go out and say cases are
going down everywhere
and then inside the task force they have
slides which say that's not true
and the places where it's growing the
fastest are mostly trump counties
you've got fox news broadcasting you
know it's time to go
and open and get back to work but a ton
of their employees are still working
from home what's being said
publicly is not matching up with the
policies that a lot of places are
putting in place
trump continues to say we don't need to
worry about testing and tracing things
are good to go everything's going down
and yet the white house over the last 72
hours has put in place a mandatory mask
policy
and daily testing for more and more
people other than
trump and pence of course they're not
wearing masks so they're
very clearly saying one thing and doing
something very different when it comes
to the policy
behind the scenes meantime i am very
pleased to see
that here in massachusetts we had
very small case growth rate for about
the last 10 days
deaths yesterday were at their lowest
since april 4th which is about
40 days ago lowest deaths in 40 days
was yesterday in massachusetts that's
really really good to see
and we're expecting some new guidance
probably in the next 48 hours
for massachusetts governor charlie baker
who's not been perfect he's been late on
a bunch of stuff
but he's been far earlier than more than
half of the country's governors
we'll see what continues to happen in
the early infection blue states like new
york
new jersey massachusetts california
illinois
and then we're going to be able to
compare and contrast that with place
with places that never really closed
at the state level uh cities may have
done things
and that have been very quick to reopen
we're going to know in the next 20 or 30
days exactly what the repercussions of
that are
early data are that it's not going to be
particularly pretty
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches giving you 15
off your entire order when you go to
davidpakman.com
slash watch don't pay thousands of
dollars for a high quality watch that
looks great because you don't have to
all of vincero's watches are made with
high-end materials
masterfully built and they look like
something you'd spend a ton of money on
but
every vincero watch ranges from about
150
to 300 bucks i went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether in
silver and white
really nice elegant look and a lot of
people ask me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really like it as well as well as
the athletic strap
it's a new year it's a new decade it's
time to reestablish your style add
something new to your look
and a high quality watch is the perfect
way to do that you can get
percent off vincero's entire collection
when you go to davidpakman.com
slash watch